the prosecution called her persistent
calculated cold-blooded
Lucy letby arriving for day three of her
trial in Manchester sat in court and
heard the prosecution allege that
working as a neonatal nurse at the
Countess of Chester Hospital let B try
to Murder One newborn girl four times
injecting air into her stomach
eventually the prosecution said she
succeeded and then sent a sympathy card
to the baby's family she was the ninth
of Lucy letby's alleged 17 victims over
the past three days the prosecution here
at Manchester Crown Court have been
outlining the various methods by which
they say Lucy letby attacked and killed
newborn babies starting in 2015 and
today the court heard that by February
2016 nine months after that first
alleged attack that her colleagues were
growing increasingly concerned and aware
of a correlation between these
unexplained baby deaths and Lucy leppy's
presence
in one event in February 2016 a
consultant felt so uncomfortable at
seeing Lucy letby alone with a baby he
decided to intervene the prosecution
said as he walked into room one he saw
letby standing over child K's incubator
she did not have her hands inside the
incubator but he could see from the
monitor that child K's oxygen saturation
level was falling dangerously however
the alarm was not sounding as it should
have been Lucy letby had not called for
help and was making no effort to help
child k
despite her colleagues concern Lucy
letby continued to work on the ward
where the prosecution say she
deliberately turned off monitors and
altered hospital records to cover her
tracks in a police search of her home in
2018 they found handwritten logs of
drugs administered to one alleged victim
and a diary entry she made noting their
near fatal collapse
hers was the malign hand behind it all
the prosecution said she was the
constant presence Lucy letby denies all
charges against her the trial resumes on
Thursday Catherine libertad Sky News in
Manchester